SEAN LEACH: Hey, everybody.
Welcome.
I'm going to be
talking today about how
to achieve Zero Downtime
Migrations using Google Cloud
or GCP along with Fastly.
My name is Sean Leach.
I'm the chief product
officer here at Fastly,
and I think it'll be a pretty
interesting conversation.
So quick background.
Fastly is an Edge Cloud.
One of the well-known
products that
has been built on top of
this Edge Cloud is CDN.
So we have quite a
few customers that
serve their content
and their application
globally around the world
using our very massive network.
Not only can they serve
content, but they can actually
build pretty complex
applications on top of this
as well and take advantage
of that scale and reach.
Our customers are kind of the
who's who out there, folks
like the New York Times, Airbnb,
Spotify, as well as jetBlue.
So I want to talk today
about three strategies
around availability
and performance.
The first one will be around
migrating from your data center
or other cloud
provider to GCP and how
you can use Fastly to do that.
I'm also going to talk
about a newer topic
but a pretty fun topic
around microservice
routing on load balancing.
You've probably heard things
like service meshes, et cetera.
We'll talk a bit about that.
Then we'll talk about
multi-cloud load balancing
strategies like how do you
use the Fastly global server
load-balancer between
cloud providers
to give you some advantages
on the performance side,
on the availability side, and
even on the cost side as well.
So load balancing is
an interesting term.
The name itself is
quite descriptive,
but I think sometimes,
folks mistake load balancing
with failover, like, oh,
if this server fails,
go to another server.
That's a component
of load balancing,
but the main focus and
use of load balancing
is around distributing
your inbound traffic
across your computing resources.
So if you have three
servers, and you
have all these customers
trying to get access
to your application,
how do you distribute
load across those servers
to best take advantage
of your infrastructure?
And then, if one of
those servers fails,
then all the traffic
will be distributed
across the two servers.
And then when that
server comes back up,
it'll redistribute that traffic
across that third server.
Traditional GSLB, and I've
been in this kind of space
a really long time.
I always used DNS previously.
So if you had
multiple data centers,
multiple clouds, your DNS server
on every single DNS request
would make a decision
whether to route the end
user to one of your other
back end infrastructure.
Now, the problem is is that
DNS queries only happen
once every so often, right?
You have this concept of
a TTL or a time-to-live
where a DNS request
will go from the client,
an answer will be
given, and then
that answer will be cached
for anywhere from one minute
to a day.
And so if you have failures
or your back ends become
overloaded, it's
very difficult to use
DNS as that routing
layer because it
doesn't respond quick enough.
Another problem with
DNS is the DNS request
comes from a recursive server.
It doesn't actually come
from the end user themselves.
And a lot of times, if
you're using Google's DNS
or Cloudflare DNS or one of
these big anycast recursive DNS
farms, your queries are
lumped in with a whole bunch
of other people's queries.
And so not only are you not
able to do load balancing
on a specific end
user level, you
aren't able to use
properties of the end user
as opposed to the DNS
server to make decisions.
And I'll talk about that second.
So Fastly GSLB is
quite a bit different.
We're what's called a
layer 7 load balancer.
And what we do is
when you make an HTTP
request to some resource that's
behind Fastly's load balancer,
we can make a decision both
on every single request
because every HTTP request
goes through us as opposed
to DNS, which gets cached.
But we also see the request come
in from the end client itself.
So we allow our customers
to make really complex load
balancing decisions based on the
properties of the end client.
So that could be a cookie value.
It could be a particular header.
It can be at the geo where
the end user is coming from,
what ISP they're using, as
well as you can take advantage
of if the back end, for example,
sets a particular cookie.
Let's say you're a
bank, and you log in.
And the bank sets
a cookie that says,
this is one of our
high profile customers.
A Layer 7 load balancer is
able to use that information
to make load
balancing decisions.
Maybe they'll send it
to the bigger compute
farm, the faster
compute farm as opposed
to the slower compute farm.
Again, I have no idea
if they would do that,
but that is a possibility.
So let's talk a bit about cloud
microservice load balancing
strategies.
You really want it to be
infrastructure agnostic,
and then, you want to have
a unified approach, right?
If you're using multiple
clouds, and they're usually
different providers,
it's nice to have
a single source of all
of your load balancing
decisions and infrastructure.
So I'm going to cover some
of that in our demos today.
But one of the beauties-- and
I'll talk a bit about this
as well-- around
multi-cloud is the ability
to take advantage
of the strengths
and avoid the weaknesses of
different cloud providers.
And so I'll talk a
little bit about how
you can use our load balancer
to take advantage of that.
So again, I talked a bit
about the functionality
that we provide.
The key points
are content-aware.
We can look at the URL
the end user's going to,
the properties of the end
user, and we can make decisions
based on that, whether
it's a microservice or just
a normal monolithic application.
Infrastructure agnostic design.
We allow you to have
a single place where
you can configure your routing
and your load balancing rules.
You don't have to have different
rules for different cloud
providers.
It doesn't matter.
As long as the back end
speaks HTTP, you can use it.
Immediate control and insights.
Like a big part
of load balancing
is understanding right away
the health of your back ends,
how the load
balancing is working
in terms of what
level of load it's
sending to this server
versus that server.
With our system, we give you
full and real-time access
to all of the logs
on every single hit
to the load balancer, which
allows you to build some really
cool analytics and
observability back end using
your favorite infrastructure
analytics provider.
And then, Scalability.
We're a massive-- many, many,
many tens of terabits a second,
tons of locations
around the world.
We instantly scale up.
So you don't have to worry about
some of the cold start problems
that you've gotten
with other load
balancing solutions or having
to buy a bunch of hardware
and support it like you've
done for the past many years.
So let's look into
Use Case Number 1.
You're in a data
center, as a lot of you
have been in the past,
and now, as a lot of folks
want to do in the future,
you want to move to GCP.
We're huge fans of GCP.
We use GCP for a lot of our
control plane technology.
And so we can definitely see
why you would want to do this.
So let's talk a bit about this.
Why would you do it?
I think it's pretty
straightforward.
You want to move
to Google Cloud,
take advantage of all
the benefits of cloud--
scalability, analytics, control.
But what do you
want to do as you
move to the cloud is you want
to make it seamless to your end
users, right?
You don't want to redirect
them to a different server
so that they see the
browser redirect.
That can have a lot of problems
when it comes to performance.
You want to make it as
seamless as possible
to move all of your traffic
from a data center provider
to a cloud provider.
And that's where a Layer
7 load balancer really
comes into its own in that
because you have a single DNS
name that everybody sees--
let's just use www.example.com--
in the layers that
have a load balancer,
you can be having
all your traffic
to go to your
primary data center.
And then, over time,
you could do it via geo.
You can do it based on
customers that have opted in.
You can send a percentage
of your traffic
to your new cloud
infrastructure.
And that way, your
end users actually
never see whether they're going
to a data center or a cloud.
All they see is www.example.com,
and behind the scenes,
you're doing all
the work to make
it really easy and
straightforward to move them
over.
And then, if there's
a problem, and you
want to move back to the
data center, it's instant.
You don't have to wait for
DNS to propagate, which again
can take up to a day sometimes.
So it's a really
powerful way of doing it.
And as a provider that's for
developers, by developers,
of course, we let everything
that you do be programmable.
Our entire UI, it
only uses the API.
We're an API-first company.
We allow you use Terraform as
well if that's the solution
that you like to use.
But what you can
see here is this
is just a simple
API call that allows
you to create a pool
that is one for GCP
and then one for
your data center.
And then once it's activated,
within a second or two
globally, that change happens.
So you don't have
to make a change
and then wait for it to
propagate for half an hour
for that traffic
to start moving.
It's an instant change
because of how quickly you
can push config changes out.
That was one of our earliest
competitive differentiators was
not only could you invalidate
content instantly--
which allowed people to put
real-time inventory behind us
or rapidly changing home pages--
we also allowed you to push
your config changes out
within a second globally.
That changed the game
on what you could
do with a CDN or an Edge Cloud.
So this is where you can create
multiple load balancers based
on different IP addresses.
So you can do local load
balancing as well or things
like service mesh, which
I'll talk about in a bit.
But it gives you
that full power.
You can have
different data centers
that you send your
traffic between,
but then you can actually
have different load balancing
algorithms between servers
within those data centers,
which is really powerful.
And then because
Fastly was originally
based on a highly modified
version of Varnish,
which is one of the most popular
caching pieces of open source
software out there.
We use a language called VCL
to do your configuration.
And so you can see here that you
can do a random load balancer
just by setting the back end.
And you can fully program this.
It's not like you only can use
a UI to make your decisions.
You have full
programmatic access
to configuring
the load balancer.
The classic example of some
folks that have used this--
there is probably the biggest
radio provider out there.
They had to quickly move
out of their data center
and into the cloud.
Their data center provider
had basically said,
you've got a week.
So using our load
balancer, they didn't
have to buy any new
gear or anything.
They just use our SAS
code base load balancer.
They slowly were able to
migrate that radio traffic
from the data center
into the cloud,
and there was no
visible artifact
of that to their end users.
Their end users had no
idea that they had moved.
They just got a lot
faster all of a sudden.
And Vimeo is another
big customer of ours.
They used this to
move from NetStorage,
which was a storage provider
of their previous CDN to using
GCS as their storage.
So they got to take advantage
of all the amazingness of GCS--
which, again, we're
huge fans of GCS.
And then, they were able to
then move that traffic off
of their old legacy
system into GCS.
So they used a really
cool feature of ours
as well where we would
actually check GCS first
as part of the move.
And if it wasn't there, if
it hadn't been migrated yet,
we'd go to the previous
storage system.
Again, all behind the scenes
unknown to the end user.
So let's talk about Use Case
2, microservices, right?
It's the new hotness, service
mesh and microservices.
And now, I'm even hearing this
thing called macroservices.
So the IT world was
always changing,
but it's always a
lot of fun as well.
Let's talk about
service-oriented architecture
or microservices routing.
So if you think about it
from a conceptual level,
it's very similar to multi-cloud
or multi-data center,
but instead, you
have multi-services.
And again, HTTP is the
language of the web.
And so as long as
everything speaks HTTP,
it's really simple.
So what you can do is you can
break that big monolithic up
into smaller sub-services
or microservices,
and then you can
use Fastly to route
based on the proper service
based on the URL path, right?
So we have a lot of customers
who have /images will go
to the image service, which
may be hosted in the same data
center or different cloud
provider, et cetera.
Then you may have a
Kubernetes service
that's running like your
shopping cart application.
So we can route anything that
goes to /cart or /product
to that particular app.
And then you might
have a third party
integration with some GraphQL
API or something like that.
So /api can go to a
different service.
And again, it's all done
on every single request
with the Layer 7 level.
And if any of those
fails, we could instantly
failover to a backup provider.
Gannett who's one of the
biggest publishers out there--
they own USA Today and
a ton of newspapers--
they use Fastly to route to all
their back end microservices.
And the other beauty
of Fastly because we're
100% both real-time
and API control,
they can integrate all this
into their CICD workflow.
So they don't have to have all
their testing and deployment
pipeline using the CICD
system, and then they're
also their load balancer,
their CDN service.
Everything is
fully programmable.
So every change that
they make, the test
is done based on their
cloud infrastructure
and the configuration
on Fastly in real time.
So they know right away
if something's going on.
You look here, very similar
API for the microservices side
where you have an images service
and you have a CMS service.
And then you might have--
here's some example VCL as well,
where, again, based on the URL,
you can see /images right there.
That would send to a
different back end,
which is the images server.
And certain things, we may
have to modify the request URL
or drain the post body.
There's all sorts of
cool stuff you can do
using the power of this system.
And then, the other really
cool thing about this
is these endpoints can be
scaled independently as well.
So the images-- if you have
multiple image providers
you're looking at using like
image optimization providers,
you can test all of
those completely,
transparently to your end users.
You can send a third of
your traffic to each one
and see which one's
faster using our logging.
You can see which one provides
a better conversion percentage
because you could set a
cookie or a header that says
which image service you chose.
And then your analytic
system could show that to you
and say, oh, provider A, I
got way better conversion
using that.
So a lot of our customers use us
for some really cool AB testing
solutions as well or
green-blue deployments.
Last Use Case I want
to talk about a bit
is just multi-cloud.
So you've moved out
of the data center.
You're using microservices.
You're pretty proud of yourself,
of the work that you've done.
Now, you're finding that you're
using just one cloud provider
out there.
There's a few
challenges with that.
I know a ton of
customers that are
cloud native with
a single provider,
and they're very happy.
But then, I hear
quite a bit from CFOs
that they don't like being so
dependent on a single provider,
both from a
availability perspective
or a monetary perspective.
One of the beauties of
the cloud is cost savings
and cost optimization.
So with multi-cloud,
you may be sitting on--
here's a graph or
a good diagram.
It talks about you may be a big
Amazon Web Services customer
and you say, you know what?
I've heard some amazing
things about Google.
I've heard they've got
amazing analytics tools.
They've got really
great technology.
I mean, that's why we're
huge Google fans is
both on the data side and
just the technology side.
You want to start moving and
taking advantage of Google,
right?
Maybe, it's you
want to do failover
between Amazon and Google.
It may be that you're
like, you know what?
I want to start moving to
Google fully as my primary,
but I want to do
it in slow order
and maybe I keep
AWS as a backup.
We have quite a few customers
like Shazam and Taboola
who have done very
similar things where they
want flexibility and options.
And so with us because of
our load balancer-- again,
completely transparent
to the user--
you can use multiple
cloud providers
and even take advantage of
the strengths of each one.
So data analytics Google
is so good at that.
You might send some of
your analytics components
of your app through Google.
But maybe you've
got this legacy app
that you've built on
Amazon that takes advantage
of a lot of their tech.
You send the traffic for
some of that to the Amazon
back ends, completely
behind www.example.com.
A lot of our customers,
they use their www record
as this single ingress
point for all traffic
so that they can not just
serve traffic and load balance
traffic to different back
ends, but maybe they've
acquired technology over time
that they need to integrate.
Again, that www record
becomes that universal source,
and it also becomes
a great audit point.
So they can tell what all of
their applications and APIs
are by logging every hit to www.
And not allowing any
traffic to anything but www,
it becomes a pretty
amazing audit system.
And then like multi-cloud
geographic load balance,
it's really cool to be
able to take advantage
of sending customers to the
locations closest to them,
right?
You may have many
Google locations where
you're running applications.
And instead of just
randomly sending traffic
to different
locations, if an end
user's coming from
New York, you want
to send to the New
York Google location.
If they're coming
from Virginia, you
want to send them to the
Virginia Google location.
If they're coming
from California,
you want to send them to
the California location.
So we geo-stamp as well as have
IP and ASN or autonomous system
information about
every single request
that we expose to the
user, so that they
can send the traffic to the
closest end user location.
And then, we health-check
all the different locations.
So in case one data
center is taken out
for maintenance
or whatever it is,
we can reroute all
that traffic instantly
to a different location.
So here's an example here.
Based on a certain path, we
create these health checks
that are constantly checking
a particular location
or a particular IP.
And it's all done
again by our API.
et cetera.
And then here's some logic
on the load balancer side
that talks about--
it looks at the server region
and it looks at the back end
and it makes different decisions
based on those properties
to send you to the
proper location.
So that's it.
Hopefully, it was helpful.
We expose all of
our documentation
online, if you go
to docs.fastly.com.
We've got an amazing developer
portal at developer.fastly.com
you can take a look at.
I'm happy to talk as well.
If you ever have
any questions of me,
it's just sean@fastly.com,
but I really
appreciate you taking
the time today.